[Music]
hi I'm tom
the software engineer at Google this is
the first video in our series using
ansible with Google cloud platform we
can use many available answer modules to
manage the various services in GCP Dylan
is here from ansible to tell us more
about how a DevOps team can take
advantage of these features available in
the engine ansible is a yamo based
language that can perfectly describe
entire infrastructures in ansible Play
Books it is also the engine that
executes these play books this execution
is performed over SSH or win RM without
an agent currently there are over a
thousand plus modules that enable these
tasks and the amount of user
contributions is impressive yeah we help
over a 2500 unique contributors at the
current time over 22,000 stars and 7,000
plus ports on github we even have
ansible books written by community
members as well over the years we've
seen ansible do some pretty unique
things
[Music]
in these next few episodes we're going
to talk about how we use ansible to
manage a satellite imaging system we
could even send commands to the
satellite via our ants we'll play Hansel
as quite a fallible powerful tool in
this video series we'll talk about how
you can use it in launching instances
deploying across region load balancer
and configuring customized networks
we'll even discuss how to build a custom
network alright so let's talk a little
bit more about that ansible controlling
of satellite saying you got going on
there
sure satellite imaging system consists
of three subsystems commanding image
processing and end-user applications so
commanding you mean it Ansel is actually
working to controlled actually on
satellite and have satellite do some
functions right yes that satellites
orbit the Earth they go in and out of
remote ground station coverage it's
ideal to place ground stations near the
poles so they will have more opportunity
to communicate with satellites in our
series we use ansible to launch some
instances run an executable on some
camera parameters and then call a custom
module to send those parameters to the
RGS okay so tell me about image
processing now
well image processing is a sensitive
issue basically images that come
directly from the satellite are not
ready for human use there is a custom
processing that needs to occur in this
series we talked about building custom
networks for both image cross the image
processing system and the remote ground
station and end-user applications allow
the user to see the processed images
correct I would expect these images to
be quite large right and you probably
have customers all over the world how do
you keep the response time low and
experience good well we use the cross
region load balancer functionality
built-ins GCP to ensure users are
getting directed to the closest data
center we'll also cover how to set this
up for danceable very cool and you
mentioned a custom module we at ansible
take a lot of pride in fact the ansible
is extensible enough for you to do that
agree to update a remote ground station
we built a custom module we can't go
over that module in detail but we can
show the audience how to build their own
modules for either internal use or to be
open sourced
so that being said let's be sure to
cover documentation and some best
practices - okay we want to hold
community built modules to the same
standards as our own delivered modules
got it
I'm looking forward to talking about
ansible and Google clouds together tall
meat soup and don't forget to check out
all of our ansible modules at the URL in
the description below
[Music]